later George with a train to catch Jacob
Evie agreed like you fragrance
Assassin's Creed syndicate is a return
to form for the storied franchise
delivering a unique engaging tale in an
open world that truly feels alive not
just in being bolts and dashes miss
Wright human voice the game feels closer
to 2009 s Assassin's Creed 2 than it
does the more recent titles because it
focuses on elements that made those
early games so soulful lovable
protagonists interesting missions with
intriguing characters a gorgeous setting
and traversal abilities that just feel
really good
the story follows twins jacob and evie
frye through 1868 london while Evie is
focused on finding a magical artifact a
piece of Eden hidden somewhere in the
city Jacob is busy building a street
gang and saving London's downtrodden
from injustice along the way they make
friends with the likes of Alexander
Graham Bell Charles Dickens and Karl
Marx just to name a few historical
figures and all these people assist them
in their mission to dismantle the city's
Templar conspiracy and protect the
little people
not only are their personalities
different so are their skills evey
special skills are stealth focused
including the incredibly useful
chameleon ability that causes her to
disappear completely while she's
standing still in sneak mode her stealth
stats far exceed her brothers so she's
your girl for bounty hunting and
liberation missions Jacob on the other
hand is a brawler more suited to
fisticuffs he takes more damage and can
bring enemies to near-death states
quicker their differences are noticeable
in gameplay and rather than have one
character you can customize either way
it's a nice convenient touch to have two
characters ready and available for
different goals
I love Jacob and Evie
the banter between these two is a
constant joy and their interpersonal
conflict is as enjoyable to watch unfold
as their external one she's serious and
tough but sweet and he's totally snarky
and a little goofy but their duality
both in the field and with one another
makes for an engaging story with some
intimate touches I find any more wild
geese for you to chase I'll be touch of
more pleasant for your absence
combat is fluid and training combos for
devastating execution moves is simple to
achieve it's easy to adapt strategy mid
battle switching to pistols and smoke
bombs in a hot second when simple blades
won't do most fights play out like a
brutal beautiful dance flying between
enemies in a gang war a brawl involving
as many as a dozen and a half combatants
on both you and the enemy side is
undeniably satisfying freerunning
follows the same simplicity you can
climb pretty much everything with
relative ease
but controls take some time getting used
to and occasionally feel
counterintuitive sometimes if you want
to climb up your character will fly away
diagonally as though they are running on
a grid so some spaces halt free running
although it happens infrequently it can
be frustrating
as for stealth you can snap in and out
at any time as you prowl the streets
nearby enemy locations and how much they
notice you are shown via a threat ring
this tool makes stealth much easier and
allows you to gauge who to take out and
when and you have a ton of options
smoke bomb them and take out the leader
escape to a rooftop and pick them off
one by one with throwing knives or make
them turn on each other with
hallucinogenic darts how you combine
your tools is up to your whims and
syndicates mission design as well as the
organic way the world lets you slip in
and out of missions gives you ample
breathing room to complete each one in
your own way I almost never use
syndicates fast travel points because
with the rope launcher why would you
take any other route through London you
become a victorian-era spider-man with
the Rope launcher you can set up air
assassinations travel across large gaps
between buildings zipline around and
quickly escape from a fight it's my
favorite item in the entire game
another new mechanic in the mix is the
systemic vehicle system carriage driving
is relatively easy to handle you can use
them for a number of things including
but not limited to hijacking them to
race down a target kidnapping hiding
corpses destroying enemies carriages or
for a simple afternoon ride with your
gang you can also get into fights on top
of them it's all very Grand Theft Auto
you even get experience point phone is's
for destroying public property easy you
can also unlock perks for your gang the
rooks I was obsessed with tricking them
out because having strong guys on the
streets meant I always had backup
in-game currency can purchase your gang
things like more well-made carriages and
give your rivals worse ones as well as
cheap access to medicine and darts you
can even pay off policemen to turn a
blind eye to your illegal activities and
assemble an army of children to collect
crafting items for you micromanaging
your gang is worthwhile because it
completely changes the social landscape
of London you have an active role in
ensuring your people are where you need
them to be when you need them to be
there and have the best tools pounds can
buy syndicates story is heartfelt and
exciting but its final boss fight is
poorly set up it tosses narrative
tension out the window and left me a
little bit disappointed but a
disappointing final fight and some
control hitches cannot diminish
Assassin's Creed syndicate charm it puts
the franchise back in touch with its
roots and presents a wonderful tale full
of heart ziplining through London is
thrilling and the organic unfolding of
missions with open-ended solutions
allows for a meaningful deeply personal
experience level believes an excellent
mission design make a sake creed
syndicate a treasure of gameplay and
storytelling
you